the open they want to be beaten down by
a bunch of older women for my bodies
bella thorne in tears over Whoopi
Goldberg's reaction to sharing her own
nude photos online you cannot be
surprised that someone has hacked you
especially if you have stuff on your
phone I'm not gonna lie I want to say
that I feel pretty disgusting you know I
feel pretty disgusting won't be knowing
everyone's ceiling you know on Tuesday's
episode of the view the talk show host
admitted she isn't exactly on the former
Disney star side while discussing
Bella's decision to release nude photos
of herself in order to take her power
back after an alleged hacker got ahold
of them if you're famous
I don't care how old you are you don't
take pictures of yourself Bella spoke
out in a series of emotional Instagram
stories Tuesday after the episode aired
watching The Sooner if you've made me
feel really bad about myself in it and I
hope you're happy I really do I really
hope you're so [ __ ] happy because I
can only imagine all of the kids who
have theirs release and then they commit
suicide once you take that picture yeah
it goes into the cloud and it's
available to any hacker who wants it and
if you don't know that in 2019 but this
is an issue you you I'm sorry your age
does not you don't get to do that
Bella revealed she'd be canceling her
scheduled interview with the view after
Whoopi's shameful comments in a lengthy
statement posted on her IG stories Bella
wrote to Whoopi in part I'm offended for
anyone out there who has ever taken a
sexy photo I'm offended for Jennifer
Lawrence who feels publicly raped your
view on this matter is honestly awful
are you serious right now this is crazy
Bella shared the nude images to her
Twitter account on Saturday in a series
of screenshots which appear to show the
alleged hacker texting her the private
photos of herself at the time Bella
revealed the hacker is being
investigated by the FBI and added the
incident made her feel gross and watched
during a time
she should be celebrating I feel like
I'm lost over here Bella just released
her fourth book the life of a wannabe
mogul mental disarray vol 1 which
contains poems chronicling her personal
struggles relationships and wild child
lifestyle if you don't like it you
[Music]